welcome to this video for round eight of
the chess olympiad in istanbul around
eight holes played on September the 5th
so i'll upload this on September 60 and
one day behind catching up after my
vacation um yeah this was around I saw
the absolute top pairing between Russia
and Ukraine the first two seats Russia
seeded first Ukraine second and Russia
one this very important match I'm
basically bye week to victory of Sergei
karaoke Nobita underwater Keaton and a
technical end game and this was some the
decisive victory with three drawers the
game wat them quite long though and not
so not so interestingly from a video
point of view so i won't show that and
yeah we also had the draw between China
and Azerbaijan 22 we're here shukria
Mammadyarov beat when you in an
interesting game which was also a
candidate for for this video and ding
Liren the junior star from China Vita
Mammadov very nice attacking game
against the Kings Indian this has also
been done on video by some other
youtubers so I ought to distance as well
yeah then we had a media beating us
Pakistan convincingly the United States
won against Macedonia and yeah and now
we come to the match which gal the game
from that i'll be covering Germany
against Hungary a very important Metro
for the medals Hungary is serve the
fourth best team in terms of iterating
and Germany as well only seated on place
14 but they are the current European
team champions and yeah they seem to be
in good shape in this term and so I
cover the top game of this match between
Arkady knowledge Germany's top layer and
Peter Leko and also of course I'm joven
myself
bit biased so to show a game of of the
jungle team for once alright so let's
see what what happened in this game nida
JH opened with 1d for which is not as
usual opening move freely here I'm crazy
for norm Liberty he mixes this mixes erm
it says moose so here we went for names
of Indian which is like awesome standard
reply to the forums oh and queens indian
defence nie Dage grade III is a very
classical line the Rubenstein system and
we get the the main line on the board
here pretty quickly seven castles and
here like has a number of opportunities
and when the NIMS 01 really came to the
forefront of chess in yeah maybe the
1950s the main move was knight c6 and
it's still a main line to this day
usually it continues along along these
lines and now black can take or I can
play Quincy seven this leads to a
typical nims of Indian battle between
the white slightly weakened horns but
the bishop pair and legs very healthy
structure however in recent years and
this is also a consequence of the huge
successes that Anatoly Karpov had with
this the continuation seat XD form he
takes d4 takes on c4 Bishop takes and b6
has come into the limelight this is very
much the main line nowadays of the e3
names of Indian and this is also very
appropriately called the capital
variation um yeah what is fled legs idea
Black has so clarified the situation in
the center and it's an isolated pawn of
course Cal professor well known
for his great abilities and playing
against I got isolated pawns and own
weaknesses so this is very M yes very
suitable variation forests are of course
it's also quite healthy for black you
will get quickly the bishop on b7 so
solving this this bishop problem and
black has no particular weaknesses and a
good development white of course enjoys
the typical it features of the isolated
d porn is got our pieces open and active
and the bishops are nice and wide
sometimes even get some initiative on
the King side so let's see how it
continues you played Bishop g5 I'm their
only a multitude of different options i
just want to show the game and here I'm
like oh played knight c6 witches a bit
uncommon in this position the most
popular way to play this is actually
Knight to d7 very often the pawn
structure that like is some is some
aiming for in this variation actually
involves him capturing on c3 which is a
bit less attractive now as the ruckus on
c1 but very often the night is simply
more flexible on d7 than it does on c6
this kind of setup was 96 pretty much
signals that like wants to yeah we treat
his Bishop on before and not exchange it
rookie one rook c8 you should be three
white retreats the bishop from C file
and yeah seems too intense and play
against hsm now this is fairly typical
in the isolated pawn and like I'm
retreated the bishop as mentioned to to
get rid of this pin and sort of from
your help defending the King side
here Y term plate also very typical move
Bishop back to be one the idea is to
play Queen d3 in the future and then set
up this this battery against h7 with the
weather with the mate threat on on this
point and what is black do ruki aid
anticipating possible you should f8
entered some point and also covering
these six which can be very useful right
now played H file and this is
interesting in fact the th poem is some
very useful um yeah attacking unit in
this kind of position as very often
after this battery is set up as shown
before leg will play the move g6 at some
point to cover age 7 and then H fry
drive is a very important resource for
white to open up the King side it's just
a bit funny to see this move played so
early but it's perfectly okay it's also
very useful to cover this bishop and
this we can um you can see in various
lines I'll show one let's play g6 now
anticipating all this Queen you three
things now I played a three because this
was one point rg6 now this move after
night before it simply doesn't make any
sense and widen needs to move the Queen
again this is why white played this oops
this this a3 move and now black played
look c7
here it is important to examine one
alternative because it's because it's a
fairly typical way to try to release
some pressure here this is 95 and here
we can see one benefit of this age
formals um let's consider the following
line 9 takes d5 if now in this position
right wouldn't have played h4 then
Bishop g5 would have been a real option
because yeah simply 9525 but here white
can simply recapture and this leads to a
quite nice position for white let's for
example look at this and not probably
taking on the aid tell me this kind of
structure in fact I was pretty surprised
that if you give this to to a strong
engine like Houdini on a good machine
that it actually gives this position as
around equal i would say that white has
a very distinct advantage here this is
some typical pawn structure rising from
isolated pawns and especially from the
loser indian cords the ram structure
like the animal of the ram because of
those pawns there somehow consider to
interlock each other's like like yeah
like on this animal yeah and this kind
of structure is very young very very
good for white because his bishop is
just better it can attack t5 what this
mission is passive on b7 and also this
kind of thing he on the King side is
very much to White's advantage so I
think why does Sam is just just better
at this position I'm surprised that the
computer actually you think this is okay
for like um and this is one point YH for
makes sense this kind of
set up of course this is not not false
black can also just recapture of course
on d5 and this could lead to something
like this we should be from Queen
retreats and define white managed to
advance the isolated pawn and this kind
of position also would be very nice for
white who just has a good pressure
against black and simply the somewhat
more active pieces note that also h4 is
very useful here that white can also
very conveniently always capture with an
ident attack f7 yeah this is nice so 95
in this position 95 wouldn't really help
like much he played this move Roxy
sandwich / protect the bishop and
possibly intense rock d7 with some
pressure on deform and white not funny
enough played Roxy tune in reply and
this is an interesting move possibly
allowing this kind of this kind of
maneuvers but played now 95 because it's
simply different now if white would
capture now on D Phi which didn't then
25 there's no we should be fall asleep
because of the rook so this is also why
white didn't take on on d5 he kept the
pieces on the board 94 yeah black not
played night would be aight i think this
is fine trying to exchange one pair of
rooks and yeah white for the moment
doesn't want to exchange you please drop
key to keeping our pieces on the board
and trying to keep maximum pressure on
like pressure here means that white has
got lots of pieces directed to the king
side it's got this age five idea and
black doesn't have firm any a great
direct counter play here's another
interesting position where i don't
understand the computers recommendation
LECO played
Queen jeez kinguggi 70 just perfectly
okay i would say showering after
kingside the computer here wants to play
f5 which is some well-known he wants to
play this and says this would be equal
I'm very surprised i would say that down
why should have a nice position here
with pressure only six and a week on a
weaker spot on only five and i cannot
really believe this should be equal I'm
very surprised about Houdini's
evaluation here I mean now computers
obviously stronger than me but well it
looks kind of weird to have all this
weaknesses and okay Lego didn't play
that King g7 i think is also just better
in fact i think he did a good job very
long for very long time in the game but
them at one pointed that got critical
now h5 of course increasing the pressure
on the King side and I'll black and
exchanged here one piece what recaptured
and ninety-seven getting the light back
this was one ideas of night PA to get
this night into into defense yeah here
white played a good move i think which I
at first didn't really appreciate but
it's a good move he played Roxy to back
and the ideas that white wants to use
his Queen on d to looking in this
direction or possibly Queen f4 at some
point of the Sun I'd should move and the
rook simply prevented this Queen d2 and
this is why he wants to exchange this
rook to get to allow the Queen to to a
go to be to like exchanged and played
Queen seven now which is perfectly okay
Queen d2 and lie to f8
yeah the old term let the odium point i
think it was by and large that with an
ID on f8 you'll never get made it well
we see in the game and it can happen but
ok 9 f8 should should help to defend the
kingside in general on it is very
obvious that like it doesn't have any
real play against yes laid upon people
are sometimes reluctant about getting an
isolated pawn but how should black ever
win this pawn white is so active on the
King's side that there's never any
serious play against the spawn ok 9 f8
now white jade Bishop to be three
looking to increase some the pressure on
this diagonal why does in this game a
little bit dumb yeah he's probing around
a bit trying here and there and trying
to provoke weakening moves but like
there were alternatives white also could
have captured on g6 for example and this
will have been also interesting one
known interesting why this is coming up
one interesting point would be that
after hm takes g6 white has the
interesting with 95 with the idea of f6
and capturing on g6 this kind of this
kind of line and it's very much unclear
who benefits from all this I would think
that black should be alright so this
wasn't an alternative for for white he
obviously doesn't need to do this
sacrifice early but okay nighty I think
wanted to keep more stuff on the board
and sort of trying to provoke some some
concession from black rook c8 and night
victory for probably intending H 697
okay he wants to
the night like to back to f6 and here i
played not F to G five there have been a
level of the Evan alternatives at this
point it could also could play tonight d
5 which was interesting the idea being
that after this move white would have a
very good good position with the idea of
capturing d5 and then getting a knight
to f6 after which black is really boxed
in here with the skin this would have
been very nice but after 95 doesn't it's
not mandatory to take like an can also
retreat this night attacking eform and
it's not clear that this really is so
great in this kind of this kind of
position why doesn't have any direct
direct mate or any direct win at its
disposal for example 95 attacking f7 can
be answered like this and I think it's
still nothing special like has some
counter play so um it isn't a very
convincing continuation 95's I think
interesting and here I think like I'm
had dumb head alternatives he took on h5
I think this is really a mistake I think
there must be some miscalculation
involved in this move what black should
do is some actually to move one night I
have six but it's not so easy to
determine which night you should move if
you look at this move which looks
perfectly natural you see that after 9 f
69 f 6 white has the very strong
continuation night XD six check and this
is surprisingly mr. to me immediately
winning
with the combination of age six here h6
King in the in the corner and then
Queenie for this is super strong
attacking the f6 night and intending
Queenie five on so like now moves the
night then there's d5 and Queen d4 and
it's just over like Anna resins us with
with a clear conscience so this night
takes six sacrifice would would win
outright so this move which looks
perfectly normal isn't working what like
could do is play this move the other way
round and the Sun I think isn't so easy
to crack um white can't play this age
six move again and here i don't i don't
really see a very direct on attacking
continuation like still seems fairly
solid he's under pressure but it's not
obvious how wide shot dumb should really
benefit from all this one one idea which
I like this kind of move to allow a
recapture with the corn if black should
should take on you for um and here's
here is no one no direct waiting for
white in fact after the game of the
continuation G takes h5 it it's very
critical right now played 93 intending
to capture on h5 but also threatening
the very strong night f5 check and here
I think like has some has no chance any
more to get get a decent game out of
this the problem simply being that King
edge age when he played directly losses
and this one which is somewhat better is
also on yeah quite um
quite for romantic for black I think
white here could could simply take on h5
and it's simply dangerous those nights
are dangerous of decking pieces so you
don't really want to play this position
or maybe you need to one funny point is
95 would sure needs to be calculated of
course it's also dangerous but it
doesn't seem to to win now so directly
let's say queen here takes on d 5 55 and
Queen f4 this looks very nice at first
with this idea attacking here and
threatening made but like has the
amazing resource Knight f6 and this is
for instance of online which she could
easily have overlooked otherwise why
would simply win but this kind of
position is actually as so playable from
like because of the strong bishop right
doesn't have a maid or any direct win
end this Bishop is some helping him with
counter play on g2 with this kind of
ideas so this is ok for black I'm King
g8 definitely after this night mg3 move
this move King g8 definitely was tougher
he played however King h8 and now
there's nine f5 coming and this is just
brutal utilizing the pin the night steps
forward attacking the Queen and yeah why
should the Queen go there's a normal
shorts let's say f6 but it really
doesn't matter on on every Queen move
this always the very strong move from 96
and this just killed it's simply a
monster fork f7 is double checked for
for check on the king the nida text the
rook and the bishop and that this is
just a just terrible so King h8 really
was a big blunder with shown Lewis
instantly you hear black simply
move they played Rock g8 and hear their
multiple wins but night in shaa finishes
very efficiently it took with this night
King to g7 and just rook takes c6 and
this is a very simple win the Queen now
yet doesn't have any any squares
available really it went to f4 could
also go to f5 but this is again very
very terrible fork on the bishop and the
Queen and that's just terrible
disposition he had played go into F form
certainly also in time trouble and now
white can can simply win with taking
Andrew p7 this is watching I displayed
and yeah like her just resigned he lose
a piece at least on the 7th rank and
probably even more and there's also the
discoveries threatened and 12 it's a
it's just a big mess which leaves black
with a complete wreck of a position yeah
a nice attacking win at the end by by
night edge um I think liquid offended
this quite well until he broke down in
in time trouble however the whole
structure that he that he got here let's
say I'm let's just go back a couple of
moves this kind of structure i think is
is simply nice to play for white he
doesn't risk much and can always try to
poke around on the gun the King side and
it's not so obvious what legs counter
play em might be I don't really like so
much this knight c6 development I like
97 more with the idea of getting play
against hanging pawns after the bishop
captures on c3 so on just just to make
this clearer let's say I'm
this kind of structure I like this more
in comparison for for black than the
game like he has some ideas both playing
d5 at some point or getting a Knight to
f4 and so on I think this is more
comfortable to play in comparison to the
isolated pawn um position type ID okay
it's a matter of meta of taste so me but
I thought night it's really had a had a
good a good game here without any any
problems and he could always try without
much risk yeah I hope you enjoyed the
game and I'll be back very soon with
coverage from round to round nine which
was played on September sixes which is
today so I finally had caught up with my
coverage yeah talk to you soon